what's a perfectly productive day in the
life of Jeff Bezos you're one of the
most productive humans in the world well
I first of all I get up in the morning
and I putter I like I like have a coffee
you find putter just like I slowly move
around I'm not as productive as you
might think I am I mean I because I do
believe in wandering and I sort of I I
you know I read my phone for a while I
read news papers for a while I chat with
Lauren I drink my first coffee um so I
kind of I mov pretty slowly in the first
couple of hours I get up early just
naturally uh and uh and then you know I
exercise most days and most days it's
not that hard for me some days it's
really hard and I do it anyway I don't
want to you know and it's painful and
I'm like why am I here and I don't want
to do this why am I here at the gym why
am I here at the gym why why don't I do
something else you know there's it's not
always easy uh what's your source of
motivation in those moments I know that
I'll feel better later if I do it and so
like the the real source of motivation I
can tell the days when I skip it I'm I'm
not quite as alert I don't feel as good
um and then there's harder motivations
it's longer term you want to be healthy
as you age you know you want Health span
you want ideally you know you want to be
health of moving around when you're 880
years old you know and so there's a lot
of but that kind of motivation is so far
in the future it can be very hard to
work in the second so thinking about the
fact I'll feel better in about four
hours if I do it now I have more energy
for the rest of my day and so on and so
on what's your exercise routine just to
linger on that what do you how much do
you curl I mean what are we talking
about
here that's all I do at the gym so I
just I I I my my routine um you know on
a good day I do about half an hour of
cardio and I do about 45 minutes of
weightlifting resistance training of
some kind mostly weights I have a
trainer who you know I love um who
pushes me um which is really helpful you
know I'll be like uh he'll
say uh Jeff J you could can we go up on
that we a little bit and I'll think
about it and I'll be like no I don't
think so and he'll be he look at me and
say yeah I think you
can and of course he's right so it's
helpful to have somebody push you a
little bit but almost every day you do
that I I do almost every day I do a
little bit of cardio and a little bit of
weightlifting and um I rotate I do a
pulling day and a pushing day and a leg
day it's all pretty standard stuff so
puttering coffee gym puttering coffee
gym and then work work so what's work
look like what what what do the
productive uh hours look like for you I
you know so I a couple years ago I left
as the CEO of Amazon and I have never
worked harder in my life
so I am I am working so hard and I
mostly enjoying it but there are also
some very painful days U most of my time
is spent on um blue origin and I've been
I'm so deeply involved here now for the
last couple of years and in the big I
love it and the small there's all the
frustrations that come along with
everything you know we're trying to get
to rate manufacturing as we talked about
that's super important we'll get there
we just hire a new CEO guy I've known
for close to 15 years now a guy named
Dave limp who I love he's amazing you
know um so we're super lucky to have
Dave and you know we're gonna you're
going to see us move faster there but so
my day of work you know reading
documents having meetings um sometimes
in person some times over Zoom depends
on where I am it's all about you know
the technology it's about the
organization it's about you know I'm
very um I I
have architecture and Technology
meetings almost every day on various
subsystems inside the vehicle inside the
engines it's super fun for me my
favorite part of it is the
technology um my least favorite part of
it is you know building organization and
so on that's important but it's also my
least favorite part so you know that's
why they call it work you don't always
get to do what you want to do how do you
achieve time where you can focus and
truly think through problems I do little
thinking Retreats so for this is not the
only I I can do that all day long I'm
very good at focusing I'm very good at
um you know I'm I don't keep to a strict
schedule like my meetings often go
longer than I plan for them to because I
believe in wandering I my perfect
meeting starts with a crisp document so
the document should be written with such
Clarity that it's like angels singing
from on high I like a crisp document and
a messy meeting and so the meeting is
about like asking questions that nobody
knows the answer to and and and and
trying to like wander your way to a
solution and um uh cuz
like and and that is if when that
happens just right it makes all the
other meetings worthwhile it feels good
it has has a kind of beauty to it it has
an aesthetic Beauty to it and and you
get real breakthroughs in meetings like
that can you actually describe the the
crisp document like this is one of the
the legendary aspects of Amazon uh of
the way you approach meetings is this
the six page memo maybe first describe
the process of of running a meeting with
memos and meetings at Amazon and blue
origin are unusual when we when we get
new when new people come in like a new
executive joins they're a little taken
back sometimes because the typical
meeting will start with a six page
narratively structured memo and we do
study hall for 30 minutes we sit there
silently together in the meeting and
read take notes in the
margins and then we then we discuss and
the Reason by the way we do study you
could say I would like everybody to read
these memos in advance but the problem
is people don't have time to do that and
they end up coming to the meeting having
only skim the memo or maybe not read it
at all and they're trying to catch up
and they're also bluffing like they were
in college having pretended to do the
reading yeah exactly it's better just to
carve out the time for people so now
we're all the same page we've all read
the memo and now we can have a really
elevated discussion and this is so much
much better from having a slideshow
presentation you know a PowerPoint
presentation of some kind where there
that has so many difficulties but one of
the problems is Powerpoint is really
designed to persuade it's kind of a
sales tool and internally the last thing
you want to do is sell you want to again
you're truth seeking you're trying to
find truth and the other problem with
PowerPoint is it's easy for the author
and hard for the audience and a memo is
the opposite it's hard to write a
six-page memo a good six- page memo
might take two weeks to write you have
to write it you have to rewrite it you
have to edit it you have to talk to
people about it they have to poke holes
in it for you you write it again it may
take two weeks so the author it's really
very difficult job but for the audience
it's much better so you can read a half
hour and you know there are little
problems with PowerPoint presentations
too you know senior Executives interrupt
with questions halfway through the
presentation that question's going to be
answered on the next slide but you never
got there whereas if you read the whole
memo in advance you you know I often
write lots of questions that I have in
the margins of these memos and then I go
cross them all out because by the time I
get to the end of the memo they've been
answered why I save all that time you
also get you know the person who's
preparing the memo we talked earlier
about um you know group think and you
know the fact that I go last in meetings
and that you don't want you know to your
ideas to kind of pollute the meeting
prematurely um you know the author of
The
memos is has has kind of got to be very
vulnerable they got to put all their
thoughts out there and they've got to go
first but that's great because it makes
them really good and so and you get to
see their real ideas and you're not
trampling on them accidentally in a big
you know PowerPoint presentation what
that feel like when you've authored a
thing and then you're sitting there and
everybody's is reading your thing you're
like I think it's mostly terrifying
yeah like maybe in a good way I think
it's a purifying I think it's terrifying
in a in a productive way yeah um but I
think it's emotionally a very
nerve-wracking experience is there uh
art science to the writing of the
six-page memo or just writing in general
to you the I mean it's really got to be
a real memo so it means you know
paragraphs have topic sentences it's
verbs and nouns you can't that's the
other problem with PowerPoint vers
they're often just bullet points and you
can you can hide a lot of sloppy
thinking behind bullet points when you
have to write in complete sentences with
narrative structure it's really hard to
hide sloppy thinking so it does it it
forces the author to be at their best
and so you're getting somebody's they're
getting somebody's really their best
thinking and then you don't have to
spend a lot of time trying to tease that
thinking out of the person and you've
got it from the very beginning so it
really saves you time the long run uh so
that part is crisp and then the rest is
messy crisp docum yes and you don't want
you don't want to pretend that the
discussion should be crisp yeah there's
you know most meetings you're trying to
solve a really hard problem there's a
different kind of meeting which we call
weekly business reviews or business
reviews they may be weekly or monthly or
daily whatever they are but these
business review meetings that's usually
for incremental Improvement and you're
look looking at a series of metrics
every time it's the same metrics those
meetings can be very efficient they can
start on time and end on
time